quisiera que levantaran la mano todos
los que pertenecen a la generación baby
boomer
ok
muy bien puede ser según lo que ustedes
les habían dicho o según esto
la generación x
la generación
y la generación zeta
[Aplausos]
lamenta si les mandamos doblemente bueno
es normal que nosotros conozcamos qué
generación pertenecemos tanto como
nuestro signo zodiacal o nuestro tipo de
sangre
y también es común que nosotros hayamos
oído algún comentario el que sea de hay
es que tu generación esto es que los de
tu generación hicieron aquello es que
los jóvenes de ahora y ok
esto siempre lleva bueno es normal que
llevan a preguntarse de otro por qué me
dices eso si yo no me siento
identificado con lo que dices en mi
generación no siento que con las
personas con las que me rodeo que
también comparten este rango y también
me lleva a pensar o sea que no somos así
y también me hace pensar si de verdad
esto nos define
la verdad es que si no podemos empezar a
entendiendo esto porque las generaciones
no son del todo exactas según esta
segunda fuente tenemos al menos unos 17
años de diferencia pero sigue habiendo
algunas algunas diferencias según los
ajustes
quisiera que levantaran la mano ahora
según qué generación pertenecen los baby
boomers
la generación x
la generación
y la generación zeta
[Aplausos]
seguimos siendo mayoría y bueno la
verdad es que esto puede ocurrir gracias
a distintos factores que son sociales
económicos y culturales y los cuales
influyen de cierta manera en nuestro
comportamiento sin bueno normalmente
siendo mayorías las que lo presentan
podemos empezar con los baby boomers que
vivieron un tiempo de un mundo
postguerra tuvieron que adaptarse a una
vida completamente diferente a la
anterior tuvieron que salir adelante
buscar estabilidad dentro de lo que
podían y sacar adelante a todos los que
vendríamos después
muchas gracias por eso además que han
establecido lo que es el mundo
actualmente con la liberación del
pensamiento y la equidad y muchas cosas
que nos permiten estar aquí ahora la
generación x la cual vino después a
pesar de que se le conoce como la
generación peterpan no sé por qué
y muestra todo lo contrario una mayor
independencia a sus progenitores porque
vivieron un mundo en el que tenían que
librarse antes empezaron con movimientos
tecnológicos aunque también seguían
mostrando
un comportamiento más de juntarse con
amigos en persona algo que después dicen
que no se nota tanto en las generaciones
que vienen y también sin mostraron
todavía el deseo de ser estables pero si
mostraban esto de querer seguir adelante
de su propia manera la generación y por
todo lo que hemos oído hablar de ella es
la que ha mostrado mayor alcance a la
tecnología y en la ruptura de la
estabilidad de querer seguir adelante
porque están acostumbrados a vivir
cambios de manera continua y por último
la generación z que vive con la
tecnología como si fuera una extensión
de su propio brazo y que somos los que
estamos estudiando ahora los que algunos
ya pronto estarán en la universidad y
que pronto tendrán el mundo en sus manos
es el momento de preguntarse de qué de
verdad es todo lo que dicen de que
nuestra generación es la que lo tiene
todo es la que tiene todas las
facilidades es la que tuvo el mejor
momento de la historia la verdad es que
no nunca han habido tiempos fáciles a
cada momento ha tenido sus ventajas y
sus desventajas problemas políticos
económicos en algunas cuestiones
culturales y este es el momento de que
se rompa esa idea cotidiana de que
vivimos bajo un estereotipo de que
tenemos que seguir ciertos patrones y
que no se pueden romper esto no es
verdad podemos aprender lo mejor de cada
una de esas generaciones y
conocer desde nuestro hermano que tiene
una generación de diferencia a nuestros
padres a nuestros abuelos nuestros tíos
que lo habrán vivido todo de una manera
completamente única y diferente
todos tienen una voz y un voto y todos
tienen derecho a expresar lo supongo que
este tipo de pláticas son lo que mejor
lo presentan
esta es mi propuesta escuchemos a todos
entendamos que cada vida ha sido
diferente y que todos tienen una opinión
y derecho para darle muchas gracias
[Aplausos]